So on to Sigmund Freud,
we're going to give him somewhat short shrift,
I'm afraid because we only have an hour to talk about Freud,
but that's okay.
Uh,
we could get a fair way through it.
Um,
he's still persona non grata,
I would say among experimental psychologists and probably clinical psychologists
swell.
But that seems to me to be very unfair.
Um,
Freud,
Freud is one of those thinkers who,
uh,
all the laughter,
his mistakes and the reason for that is that everything that he discovered or
put forward is so entrenched in our culture now that we think it's self evident.
And so everything correct has been assimilated and that just leaves everything
that's more or less floating on top to look wrong.
And,
but Freud is also one of those thinkers who was always wrong in an interesting
way.
And that's very useful.
And so,
um,
I also think that many of the things that he put his finger on,
that our ups of still disputed,
for example,
the idea of the Oedipus complex are much more useful than people are willing to
admit,
especially in the clinical realm.
Because the oedipal complex,
which we'll talk about quite a bit,
is actually a description of a fairly stable form of familial psychopathology
where child gets trapped within the confines of a family because the
relationship with one parent or the other or both is so tight that they can't
break beyond it.
And maybe because of their own inability to move towards independence,
but more frequently because of,
uh,
what you might describe as a kind of conspiracy between the sun and the parent
or the child and the parent,
uh,
that prevents them from moving towards autonomous life and keeps them in a state
of essentially a state of childhood dependence.
Freud said,
I started my professional activity as a neurologist trying to bring relief to my
neurotic patients under the influence of an older friend.
And by my own efforts I discovered some important new facts about the
unconscious and psychic life,
the role of instinctual urges and so on.
Out of these findings grew a new science psychoanalysis,
a part of psychology and a new treatment for the neuroses.
I had to pay heavily for this bit of good luck.
People did not believe in my facts and thought my theories unsavory.
Resistance was strong and unrelenting.
In the end I succeeded in inquiring pupils and building it up,
an international psychoanalytic association,
but the struggle is not over.
He made that recording just shortly before he died.
He moved to La,
to England to escape the Nazis.
Before Freud,
I guess
the mind was,
it's complicated because Freud of course was not the only person to be thinking
along the lines that he thought.
Pierre Jenay who was one of his teachers had originated and started to develop.
Many of the ideas that I would say were popularized by Freud,
but
the idea of the unconscious mind was not certainly not as well developed prior
to Freud as it became afterwards and
before that.
I suppose
you might say that in so far as people thought of the mind at all,
they they thought in philosophical terms and the mind would be that part of you
that's that you're aware of like in the dark and the Cartesian sense.
Descartes said,
I think therefore I am and it kind of seems in some sense self evident that
you're aware of and have control over the contents of your own mind.
But that was what Freud really questioned and he questioned it,
deeply said,
well first of all the idea that you're one thing like one mind is a dubious idea
to begin with because people are full of internal contradictions and then the
idea that your mind is all of one type,
it's all of one form was also very questionable as far as Freud was concerned
because you could be fractionated into subcomponents and you know the idea for
example,
that your anger or your sexual desire could be an autonomous part of your
personality in some sense that it could overtake you and control you.
That's really a Friday and idea and one of the classic Freud and ideas really is
that people are made out of sub personalities and those subpersonalities are
alive.
And that's one of the things I really like about the psychoanalytic thinkers
because even the psychologists who say over the last 30 years or there abouts
since maybe longer now anyways,
since the demise of behaviorism as an ideology
and the admission by psychologists that there were,
there is an active unconscious or many active unconsciousness,
which is a better way of thinking about it.
Psychologists still really haven't come to terms with the idea in any deep sense
that these unconscious processes are living things.
You know there when when psychologists talk for example about the cognitive
unconscious,
they're talking about something that they described it more machine like with
more machine like metaphors and that's not reasonable.
You you understand things a lot better if you understand that the subcomponents
that make up people,
the fragmentary bits of them and also the biological subsystems that that are
part and parcel of your being are much more intelligently viewed as
personalities there.
They're kind of unit dimensional personalities in some sense so that for
example,
if you're angry,
you're nothing but angry.
I mean that's an overstatement obviously.
Or if you're afraid you're nothing but afraid or if you're hungry,
you're nothing but hunger.
While that's certainly true,
if you get hungry enough or thirsty or too hot or any of those things,
you,
you kind of collapsed to a simpler personality that only has one motivation in
mind.
And we'll talk a lot as we progress about the grounding of those unit
dimensional motivational systems in biology.
But I'd have to say that Freud was among the first read least the first to
synthesize a coherent theory of this multiplicity and to put it forth,
well also insisting that much of what was happening to you and inside of you was
not immediately accessible to your awareness.
And it's a very profound,
it's very profound discovery.
It means among any among many other things that you can formulate ideas.
First of all,
it means that you can act out things that you don't understand for reasons that
you don't understand.
It also means that your memory can contain things that's represented in one way,
but that can't be understood in another.
So for example,
and we know this is true because there are independent memory systems,
there's an independent memory system for procedures.
That's for actions.
There's an independence memory system for what you might describe as imagination
for,
for the memory that uses images.
And then there's uh,
another system that articulates knowledge.
That's the semantic memory system.
And it's not obvious at all that the contents of all of those are equivalent.
And that's why,
for example,
you can dream things that you don't know.
Cause one of the things you might think is that your dreams watch you act and
they watch other people act and then they make a little drama out of that.
And that drama has information in it.
But you don't necessarily know what that information is in that.
You can't describe it consciously.
Right.
It's,
it's akin to the Ph Eddie and idea that kids can play a game and you can take
them away from the game and then they won't know how to describe the rules,
even though they can play the game.
And so dreams can contain information that's full of the encoding of behavior
that has information in it that you're not consciously aware of.
And so then you can become consciously aware of that in kind of a revelation
side.
Maybe that's what you do when you become aware of the meaning of a dream or the
meaning of a fantasy or something like that.
And that's all,
all our ability to think that way in some ways can be traced back to France.